في الخارج الآن ، الدكتورة أندريا سيرسيك ، أخصائية الأورام في Memorial Sloan Kettering
، كانت جزءًا من فريق البحث الذي
أجرى هذه الدراسة آه و dr cersek
تعلمون بالطبع عندما رأيت هذا ،
أعتقد أن الجميع
يفعلون ذلك عندما يسمعون العنوان الرئيسي أن السرطان يمكن
أعني أنه يبدو مستحيلًا ، إنه
بالتأكيد أمر رائع
من وجهة نظرك ، كم
هي رائعة النتيجة التي لاحظتها ،
إنها مذهلة تمامًا لم
نتوقعها بالتأكيد لم نشهد
هذا من قبل
إنه حقًا ما تعرفه حقًا أن أحلام أطباء السرطان
تتحقق  من رؤية استجابة
مثل هذه ، مثل هذه الفعالية المذهلة
مع عدم وجود سمية تقريبًا ،
يشعر مرضانا بالارتياح بعد
العلاج بوظيفة الجسم الطبيعية تمامًا
في شيء مثل
سرطان المستقيم حيث تكون
علاجاتنا عادةً شديدة السمية ، لذا
فهو أمر لا يصدق على الإطلاق ،
لذا يمكنك  أخبرني المزيد عن العقار الذي
أفهم أنه يسمى
دوستارليماب ولماذا تعتقد أنه نجح ،
لذا فهو مناعي  apy um وهو يعمل
عن طريق فتح الجهاز المناعي الطبيعي
للجسم لمحاربة السرطان وهذا النوع
من العلاج يعمل في خلايا سرطانية محددة أه
وقصور في القولون والمستقيم غير متطابقة مع
نقص الإصلاح لذا فهي تفتقر إلى
الجين الذي يمكنهم من إصلاح
الحمض النووي الخاص بهم و  بسبب ذلك لديهم
العديد من الطفرات والجهاز
المناعي يتعرف على السرطان على أنه غريب
، وبالتالي عندما نعطي العلاج المناعي
مثل نجم النجم ، فإنه في الحقيقة يعمل على زيادة سرعة
الجهاز المناعي بحيث يرى
السرطان ويتخلص منه ، ولكن ما هو
رائع جدًا  هنا أنه
يقضي تمامًا على السرطان الذي اختفت منه الأورام للتو